and i always like since i was little i
think i had a vision of like at one
point
in my life i'm gonna have a certain
whether it's celebrity or platform to
have a voice and have an impact and
at that point i thought it was it's
really ironic for young women because i
had such a hard time in high school
that i was like if i could just help
women with their self-esteem
well girls i guess before they became
women or i didn't even i didn't know
what exactly but i was like i'm gonna
have a voice
like and acting was not it so
when i got introduced to esp which
everyone knows is nexium
it was like oh my goodness maybe this is
my my tribe maybe these are my people
right so how did so how did this happen
how old you're 25 26 and you just
is it on a bulletin board does someone
because i think well
it's mark mark kind of brought you in
right mark how did you become friends
with mark who directed a movie a
documentary
which was a big documentary called what
the bleep do we know correct yes
what the belief it's called not what the
bleep do we know just what the belief we
just
actually just call it bleep just bleed
so how did you meet him and then how did
this all happen
so and i still have to get you a copy of
the book because it goes into much more
detail about this
guard is
and it goes into a lot more detail than
the vowel especially about this part of
my life which was
i think you know not very long but it
was a real quest i'd watch with the
bleep i'd read things like the artist's
way
um celestine prophecy it was in the
beginning of my like spiritual journey
i've done that and we watched with the
bleeper bleep and we loved it
and then my boyfriend at the time was a
filmmaker got us
into a film festival where he was like
you know uh as a director and i said i'm
coming with you because it was called
the spiritual cinema circle festival at
sea
this doesn't exist anymore it's run by
an amazing man named steven simon who
uh directed what dreams may come with
robin williams right just this
really great guy anyway it's a long
story but this long and short of it is
the very first night they sat me down
with the director of what the bleep
assigned seating
and uh we had a conversation that uh
changed my the trajectory of my life and
he told me about nexium and ultimately
i never googled it i never you know
checked into it i just like well i like
him i like with the bleep and he's
telling me about this group of people
that are
working together to shift humanity like
[Applause]
this is it i was looking for my purpose
and landed in my lab this must be
you